sometimes you'll see people say this is
backed by science or this is proven by
studies and you'll see a list of
citations but this doesn't mean much
there are a lot of bad studies out there
and it can be really tricky to work out
if a study actually backs up what
someone is saying a lot of the time
abstracts and conclusions will
exaggerate what a study found for
example here's a study that color
science did on how well their products
protected against blue light you would
think that zinc oxide is great for blue
light protection and this is what a lot
of brands and magazine articles and
experts dermatologists estheticians are
saying probably based on this study but
if you actually look at the study they
didn't compare products with and without
zinc oxide so they had zero evidence for
this conclusion and with the products
they did test the product with the least
zinc oxide gave the most blue light
protection which is the opposite of what
they're implying other better design
studies have found that zinc oxide
doesn't give good protection against
blue light even if you have a really
thick white layer so be really careful
when reading studies don't just trust
what they